other than that i mean it's been a ton
of communicating
uh and and
most of what we're communicating is not
really data science
it's more the value like the value
proposition of what we're doing
and why we're doing it very very we
always have
one slide on like our our technology
stack
that encompasses you know our studio aws
snowflake data vendors
that's all kind of put onto one one
slide of like a 10
slide deck so other than that we're
always just talking about
the value we're bringing how it's going
to help non-data scientists
that's like a huge theme at the bank
you know it's always about it's always
about lifting up teammates
you know so if data science can help
enhance other people's work that's
always like
something people are very very
supportive of
upskilling do you know a lot of people
are interested in that but
but it's a lot of work to help upskill
people but if
if you can find people who are willing
to take on that work
i think it's that's a big win also but
that's really a lot of work
it's very time consuming um especially
i mean at a big organization that's been
like a nine month project
just kind of getting on the the training
calendar of okay we want to start up
skilling people on data science
teaching people about r et cetera um
you know creating the content and doing
it that's like the easy part
getting it getting it on the docket has
been the hard part but
but uh i i definitely think
that trying to position data science
as something that helps other people has
been really important for us
just because again there's there's some
hesitancy about data science there's
some hesitancy about
this new thing this new technology that
could kind of take over
what other people are doing so um
yeah i think that that's been helpful
too um
so that was a positioning data science
is something that helps other people and
finding other
like other little pockets of data
science champions has has been
has been a good way for us to approach
things
and help us figure out who we need to
talk to about different initiatives
you